let's go with Co with some caution and
trepidation to Oz from Kentucky laws
last time we heard from you you weren't
doing great and I'm hoping that you're
doing better today
hey can you hear me yes I can
yeah I'm doing a lot better David uh I
haven't talked to you in a couple years
actually I don't think has it been that
long
I don't think I've talked to you even
since my grandma passed away from Coven
in like 2000. oh well I'm sorry to hear
that
like uh I ran for congress did I tell
you that yeah yeah we spoke around the
time of that
oh okay I don't I didn't I didn't
remember telling you that I ended up I
ran as an independent
against Thomas Massey and I ended up
getting uh 10 000 and uh
I think ten thousand over ten thousand
votes I got four percent of the the is
that right
so I got the most votes for an
independent in my District's history and
I think I'm the only open socialist
that's ever ran in this District so oh
that I see it right is it okay to say
your name I mean you're a public person
can I say your name
sure yeah so I'm seeing here the results
Ethan Osborne you got 10 000 votes four
percent of the vote that's fantastic
that's good I mean Massey is sort of
like a big time incumbent
yeah he's uh he's won every election
since 2012 when he took office yeah
which is pretty he's one of those
fascinating
Marjorie Taylor green as far as his
politics so what's what's next now
um I don't know I I think I'm just going
to help other people I have a friend
who's running as a Democrat for State
Rep and I'm just I think I'm just going
to help other people's campaigns uh next
cycle
and I'm just more focused on organizing
and um you know direct action and
activism for now
um that's fantastic and listen Oz you're
doing it in a place where it's so needed
which is Kentucky I get calls all the
time from people who are basically ready
to abandon their red States because they
need to for their family or for whatever
reason and I respect that but I also
greatly respect what you're doing which
is you're staying in the place and
you're doing what you can to improve it
yeah it's and it's tough too I mean
we've got some real
problems with fascism here that's
getting worse in this area
um and I'm I have I don't have much
choice because you know I have shared
custody of my son until I turned until
he turns 18 so right
um so I'm here for him
um wow and so well listen I hope that
you will rack up some improvements be
they modest or big in in your area this
is the critical thing how can we improve
the place where we live and that's what
you're trying to do
absolutely yeah I think everyone greet
the mutual Aid networks right now as
much as possible because uh I think the
left needs to start prepping I think
that's imperative
yeah there is a left prep Movement by
the way that's an interesting thing you
bring up listen Oz it's so great to hear
you sounding so good I really appreciate
you calling in
thanks for taking my call all right
there is Oz from Kentucky four percent I
mean listen it's nothing to sneeze at
nothing to sneeze at whatsoever uh and
so uh so great to hear from Oz all right
everybody we will take calls again just
not today okay just not today I'm out of
time and I will speak to everybody very
soon quick break and then right back as
the Friday show continues